What is hydraulic
fracturing? Oh, fracking.
Since the industrial revolution, our
energy consumption has risen unceasingly.
The majority of this energy consumption
is supplied by fossil fuels like coal or
natural gas.
Recently,
there's been a lot of talk about a
controversial method of extracting natural
gas,
hydraulic fracturing or fracking.
Put simply,
fracking describes the recovery of natural
gas from deep layers inside the earth.
In this method, porous rock is
fractured buddy use of water, sand,
and chemicals in order to
release the enclosed natural gas.
The technique of fracking has
been known since the 1940s
nonetheless, only in the last 10 years
has there been quite a fracking boom,
especially in the USA.
This is because most conventional
natural gas sources in America and on the
European continent have been exhausted.
Vast prices for natural gas and
other fuels are rising steadily,
significantly more
complicated and expensive.
Methods like fracking have now
become attractive and profitable.
In the meantime,
fracking has already been used more
than a million times in the USA alone.
Over 60% of all new oil and gas
wells are drilled by using fracking.
Now let's take a look at how
fracking actually works. First,
the shaft is drilled several hundred
meters into the earth. From there,
they horizontal hole is drilled
into the gas bearing layer of rock.
Next, the fracking fluid is pumped into
the ground using high performance pumps.
On average, the fluid consists
of 8 million liters of water,
which amounts to about the daily
consumption of 65,000 people plus several
thousand tons of sand and about
200,000 liters of chemicals.
The mixture penetrates into the rock
layer and producers in numerable tiny
cracks. The sand prevents the
cracks from closing. Again,
the chemicals perform various tasks. Among
other things, they compress the water,
kill off bacteria or dissolve minerals.
Next,
the majority of the fracking fluid is
pumped out again and now the natural gas
can be recovered as soon as
the gas source is exhausted,
the drill hole is sealed.
As a rule,
the fracking fluid is pumped back into
deep underground layers and sealed in
there.
However,
fracking is also associated
with several considerable risks.
The primary risk consist in the
contamination of drinking water sources.
Fracking not only consumes
large quantities of fresh
water, but in addition,
the water is subsequently
contaminated and is highly toxic.
The contamination is so severe that
the water cannot even be cleaned in a
treatment plant
even though the danger is known and
theoretically could managed in the USA
already sources have been
contaminated due to negligence.
No one yet knows how the enclosed water
will behave in the future since they
have not yet been any long
term studies on the subject.
The chemicals used in fracking very from
the hazardous to the extremely toxic
and carcinogenic such as
benzol or formic acid.
The company's using fracking and say
nothing about the precise composition of
the chemical mixture,
but it is known that there are about 700
different chemical agents which can be
used in the process.
Another risk is the release
of greenhouse gases.
The natural gas recovered by
fracking consists largely of methane,
a greenhouse gas, which is 25 times
more potent than carbon dioxide.
Natural gas is less harmful than
coal when burned, but nonetheless,
the negative effects of fracking or the
climate balance, our overall greater,
firstly, the fracking process requires
a very large consumption of energy.
Certainly the drill holes are quickly
exhausted and it's necessary to drill.
Fracking holds much more frequently
than for classical natural gas wells.
In addition,
about 3% of the recovered gas is lost
in the extraction and escapes into the
atmosphere.
So how is fracking and its
expected benefits to be
assessed when the advantages
are balanced against the
disadvantages when properly employed?
This technique offers one way in the short
to medium term to meet our demand for
lower cost energy.
But the longterm consequences of fracking
are unforeseeable and the risk to our
drinking water thus should
not be underestimated.